[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis einen schönen guten
abend und herzlich willkommen zum sport
begrüßte norbert lehmann gutendorf vor
mir liegen wir auf die wichtigen themen
heute
aufrüsten gegen omikron
gesundheitsminister lauterbach sieht
mehr und schnellere booster impfungen
als zentralen baustein
fdp rückt in die mitte der bundestag
beschließt eine neue sitzordnung gegen
ihren willen sitzt künftig die union
neben der afg und
lebenslanger haft der amokfahrer vom
rosenmontagszug in volkmarsen wird wegen
mordversuchs in 89 fällen verurteilt
an den neuen namen müssen sich viele
sicher noch gewöhnen stadt sparen wieder
heißt es jetzt lauterbach wähler das
prinzip aber bleibt das gleiche
bundesgesundheitsminister und rk ii chef
informieren über die aktuelle corona
lage und da gibt es durchaus auch
ermutigendes wie einen neuen rekord
schauen wir uns einmal die entwicklung
an mitte mai und anfang juni wurde mit
täglich 1,4 millionen dosen besonders
fähige und das wurde gestern noch einmal
übertroffen fast eineinhalb millionen
impfungen die meisten davon 1,3
millionen waren auffrischimpfungen der
booster boom hält also an aber nun
bekräftigt der bundesgesundheitsminister
ist mangelt an impfstoff und wie geht es
eigentlich mit dem impfen von kindern
weiter ins land gehen
wenn's den kleinsten hilft die angst vor
der spritze zu nehmen ist hausarzt ingo
löffler in niedersachsen gerne auch mal
kostümiert bei ihm ist der andrang groß
für ausreichend stoff ist gesorgt
dass wir die möglichkeit haben jetzt so
schnell impfen zu lassen weil wir auch
ältere leute in unserem umfeld haben und
weil sie dich schon sagt die schulklasse
mit 30 kindern sehr groß ist wie schon
quarantäne zeiten hinter uns hatten ganz
anders die sorgen
es ist sein erster auftritt vor der
hauptstadtpresse
als bundesgesundheitsminister da muss
karl lauterbach erst einmal klarstellen
dass für seine ehrgeizige booster
kampagne der impfstoff nicht ausreicht
20 millionen dosen zählen versucht uns
ausdrücklich keine kritiker meinen
vorgänger wir haben halt alles sehr
offensive booster impfung strategie zu
unserem also hauptwerkzeug gemacht und
dafür braucht sehr viel impfstoff und
dafür braucht man den impfstoff schnell
die gute nachricht es wird so viel wie
möglich nachgestellt und aufgekauft
moderner liefert noch im dezember zehn
millionen zusätzliche dosen die
schlechte nachricht am nikon die neue
variante wir können noch nicht
einschätzen ob und wie kommen ähnlich
oft schwere verläufe verursacht wie
delta oder vielleicht auch weniger krank
macht oder mehr krank macht boostern so
schnell wie möglich die losung gestern
erst 1,5 millionen impfungen dieses
tempo will lauterbach halten ein
entzücken im termin kann er allerdings
nicht ausschließen
typischerweise der impfschutz so nach
einiger zeit
nachlässt könnte sehr gut sein dass eine
nikon spezifische impfung später
notwendig wird für das kommende jahr hat
lauterbach bereits 80 millionen dosen
vorbestellt vorsorglich auch für eine
fürth impfung
blicken wir auf die korona lage in
zahlen das robert koch institut meldet
1677 neue infektionen innerhalb eines
tages fast 14.000 weniger als vor einer
woche die inzidenz sinkt weiter auf
jetzt 3 140,1 die zahl der todesfälle
bleibt auf einem hohen niveau
522 menschen starben innerhalb eines
tages an oder mit kubik 19
seit tagen gilt im einzelhandel dass man
geimpft oder genesen sein muss um
einzukaufen
ausgenommen sind geschäfte des täglichen
bedarfs in niedersachsen ist diese zweig
regel jetzt gekippt worden vom
oberverwaltungsgericht in lüneburg
die maßnahme sei zur weiteren eindämmung
des corona virus nicht notwendig und
auch nicht mit dem allgemeinen
gleichheitsgrundsatz vereinbar entschied
das gericht
die baustellen für meinen nachfolger
sind groß so hatte sich merkel von der
europäischen union verabschiedet wie
groß sie sind erfährt olaf scholz jetzt
selbst heute ist er bei seinem ersten
eu-gipfel als kanzler die staats und
regierungschefs und chefinnen ring darum
gemeinsame antworten beim umgang mit
russland und in der frage der chor ohne
regeln gunnar kraus brüssel ein
eu-gipfel zweimal streit zum einen geht
es um den kampf gegen omikron belgien
brewster hat nach vier monaten die
niederlande nach 3 italien verlangt bei
einreise pcr oder schnelltests
griechenland auch ohne die nur während
der weihnachtszeit der mit der zeit
gewinnen um so viele menschen wie
möglich zu fuß
es ist ein comeback mit zeit
andere warnen eine testpflicht auch für
geimpfte entwerte europas im zertifikat
wenn es nachher aber nur pcs sind und
nicht mehr im zertifikat und hab ich ein
problem weil dann hab ich überhaupt gar
keine motivation den leuten zu sagen
sollen auch geimpft werden der zweite
streit geht um die reaktion der eu
sollte russland die ukraine eingreifen
olaf scholz will abschreckung und dialog
deshalb werden wir hier heute noch mal
betonen dass die unverletzbarkeit der
grenzen eine der ganz wichtigen
grundlagen des friedens in europa ist
und dass wir alle gemeinsam alles dafür
tun werden dass es bei dieser
unverletzbarkeit auch tatsächlich glatt
doch was ist alles und soll die eu das
schon benennen das ist umstritten
welche formen der sanktionen einsetzt
muss man ganz genau timen ab wann man
das sagt das richtige timing wäre jetzt
sagen baltische staaten die richtige
sanktion wäre ein stopp für nord stream
wir werden das zum thema machen wenn das
ist ein instrument das sehr starke
wirkung auf russland haben könnte in
relation zu frisch doch das treffe auch
deutsche firmen deutsche interessen
merkel jede sanktion die russland
abschrecken könnte hätte folgen in der
die eu ist sich also nicht einig wie sie
mit russland umgehen soll anne gellinek
wie wir die europäische union denn dann
für den fall der fälle russland
gegenüber treten darüber beraten die
staats und regierungschefs und chefinnen
gerade abhörsicher und mit
eingeschlossenen handys der plan ist
natürlich dass man russland möglichst
geschlossen und mit einer stimme
sprechend gegenübertritt aber das kann
nur funktionieren wenn man die
strafmaßnahmen die angedachten möglichst
im unkonkreten lässt denn sonst droht
streit jede maßnahme die moskau wirksam
treffen würde so wie zum beispiel das
abschneiden russischer banken vom
internationalen finanzsystem hätte eben
auch negative folgen für europäische
unternehmen und so treffen sich hier
länder mit wirtschaftsinteressen die
sanktionsliste reich und luxemburg mit
ländern die am liebsten heute noch
sanktionen gegen moskau beschließen
würden wie die polen und die balten sie
sind es auch die versuchen den druck auf
deutschland zu erhöhen dass deutschland
im falle eines falles die gaspipeline
aus dem 2 nicht in betrieb nehmen dürfe
kanzler scholz lässt diese kritik
bislang an sich abtropfen er versucht
hier auf seinem ersten eu-gipfel in
brüssel eine art vorsichtigen mittelweg
einerseits sanktionen jahr andererseits
ein angebot des dialogs an moskau
dankeschön für diese einschätzung anne
gellinek vom eu gipfel in brüssel danke
und wir kommen zurück nach berlin seit
monaten gibt es streit im bundestag über
die frage welche fraktion neben der afg
sitzen soll bisher sind die linken im
plenum ganz links zu finden daneben
gruppiert sich die spd dann die grünen
neben den grünen die union dann die fdp
und schließlich die afd ganz rechts nun
rückt allerdings die fdp mehr die mitte
und tauscht mit der union die plätze die
schäumt lassen sagt über eine emotionale
abstimmung
es sind die liberalen die bereits seit
jahren darauf drängen die sitzordnung im
bundestag zu ändern sie sehen sich als
partei der mitte und wollen
dementsprechend im plenum platziert
werden
das links-rechts-schema der politik ist
ganz offenkundig dass nachdem dieser
deutsche bundestag bei seinen fraktionen
mit einer ausnahme sortiert ist jeder
kann das sehen jede besucherin jeder
besucher der hier den plenarsaal erklärt
bekommt versteht das und sie das steht
doch auch die unionsfraktion hat keine
lust auf nachbarschaft zur afd verweis
auf eine 70 jahre alte tradition die die
neue regierung mal so eben über bord
werfen
sie möchten uns von unseren plätzen an
den rand des plenums drücken sie möchten
einen monolithischen regierungs block in
der mitte statuieren sie möchten für die
mehrheit die zentralen plätze hier im
plenum haben und es ist nicht in ordnung
tatsächlich hat sich die fdp immer
wieder beschwert über verbale attacken
und mehr durch die neben ihr sitzende
fdp fraktion ihr redner heute scheint
mit seinen entgleisungen diese vorwürfe
zu bestätigen mehr die sich so an die
macht heranrückt desto
blasierter wurde diese machtversessene
macht vergessene grün links die rote
posten grapscher truppe von der fdp am
ende stimmt der bundestag gegen die
union für eine neue sitzordnung in den
nächsten wochen müssen also noch mal die
handwerker ran
und jetzt ein wichtiges wirtschaftsthema
inflation seit monaten steigen den
westlichen industrieländern die preise
für sprit heizkosten und konsumartikel
gestern hat die us-notenbank auf die
teuerungsrate reagiert und einen
zinsanstieg für kommendes jahr in
aussicht gestellt und wie reagiert die
europäische zentralbank die verkündete
heute der leitzins bleibt bei
historischen 0 prozent die
inflationsrate in deutschland lag wie
man hier sehen kann zuletzt bei 5,2
prozent stefan schlosser mit den
einzelheiten
die us-notenbank hat vorgelegt die
britische setzte heute noch einen drauf
und erhöhte den leitzins als erster der
großen notenbanken an dass die ezb hier
geht man weiterhin von nur zeitweilig
steigenden preisen aus
im laufe des jahres 20 22 erwarten wir
eine stabilisierung der energiepreise
eine normalisierung des
verbraucherverhaltens und ein abklingen
des preisdrucks aufgrund globaler
lieferengpässe
die gigantische corona krisenhilfe mit
einem volumen von
1,85 billionen euro will die ezb im märz
war auslaufen lassen doch das heißt
nicht dass künftig weniger geld im
umlauf ist oder nicht jederzeit
nachgelegt werden könnte in puncto
inflationsbekämpfung maßnahmen der ezb
in keinster weise aus man müsste hermann
die inflationsbekämpfung ernst nimmt
sofort und nachhaltig die zinsen erhöhen
die liquidität absaugen damit inflation
bekämpft wird die ezb hat sich selbst in
eine zwickmühle gebracht sagen experten
einerseits ist die inflation deutlich
angestiegen weit über das zwei prozent
ziel hinaus und andererseits muss sie
wahrscheinlich weiterhin staatsanleihen
von hoch verschuldeten euro staaten
ankaufen um eine größere finanz und
schuldenkrise im euroraum zu verhindern
weiterhin lockere geldpolitik weiterhin
höhere inflationsraten für verbraucher
sind das keine guten aussichten in
köln hat die polizei vier männer
festgenommen die material zum bombenbau
gekauft haben sollen die verdächtigen
werden zum teil der rechtsextremen szene
zugerechnet
am morgen durchsuchten spezialkräfte die
wohnungen der männer der staatsschutz
ermittelt mobiltelefone und datenträger
werden ausgewertet
wie groß die gefahr von rechts ist zeigt
der anschlag von hanau vor knapp zwei
jahren erschoss dort ein rechtsextremer
deutscher neuen menschen gab es mittäter
anstifter oder mitwisser damit hat sich
die bundesanwaltschaft beschäftigt und
das verfahren dazu jetzt eingestellt der
täter habe alleine gehandelt der 43
jährige hatte im februar 2020 aus
rassistischen gründen neun menschen mit
migrationshintergrund erschossen
anschließend tötete er in seinem
elternhaus seine mutter und sich selbst
gegen den amokfahrer von volkmarsen er
ging heute das urteil lebenslange haft
wegen versuchten mordes in 89 fällen
nach überzeugung des gerichts hatte der
31 jährige sein auto absichtlich und
ungebremst in einen rosenmontagsumzug
gesteuert vor knapp zwei jahren war das
dabei verletzt er viele menschen schwer
darunter zahlreiche kinder susanne
santina berichtet
viele menschen aus volkmarsen sind heute
zum landgericht kassel gekommen auch mit
der hoffnung doch noch etwas über die
motive des täters zu erfahren
lebenslange haft mit dem vorbehalt der
anschließenden sicherungsverwahrung
heißt es schließlich für den angeklagten
sein anwalt hatte durchgesetzt dass er
zur urteilsverkündung nicht gefilmt
werden durfte die anklage ist mit dem
urteil zufrieden weil der angeklagte
ebenso eine
rücksichtslose und äußerst gefährliche
tat handlung durchgeführt hat die nach
ansicht des gerichts eben auch von
erheblicher krimineller energie geprägt
war es war der 24
februar 2020 als [ __ ] s p mit seinem
wagen ungebremst in den
rosenmontagsumzug in volkmarsen fährt
menschen werden durch die gegend
geschleudert er leiden unter anderem
schwerste kopfverletzungen auch kinder
s&p hatte seine amokfahrt geplant und
wollte sie filmen mit einer kamera in
seinem auto diese bilder stammen vom
prozessauftakt im märz der angeklagte
habe eine narzisstische und paranoide
persönlichkeitsstörung so der richter
heute er hatte sich bis zum schluss
nicht zu seinem motiv geäußert das sei
sein recht und nicht zu bewerten sagt
sein anwalt
sein entschluss und das muss das gericht
so hinnehmen für die opfer des
amokfahrers sei das aber eine
zusätzliche belastung betont der
bürgermeister von volkmarsen dass dieses
warum nicht beantwortet wird denn dann
hätte man vielleicht gewisse
schlussfolgerungen daraus ziehen können
so bleibt das unbeantwortet und wird
natürlich jemand stück weit bei den
menschen im gedächtnis haften bleiben
viele prozessbesucher aus volkmarsen
halten das strafmaß für gerechtfertigt
doch sie werden sicher lange brauchen um
das erlebte zu verarbeiten
seit jahren wird die arbeit von
medienschaffenden immer gefährlicher
reporter ohne grenzen berichtet 20 21
sei die zahl inhaftierter
journalistinnen um 20 prozent gestiegen
auf mindestens 488 ein neuer trauriger
rekord knapp die hälfte der fälle
betrifft die drei länder china und
belarus die zahl spiegelt wider wie
skrupellos sich autoritäre machthaber
weltweit verhielten so eine sprecherin
der organisation
wir kommen wir zum wintersport norbert
lief nicht so gut wie deutschen
ja bei den frauen wurde ramona
hofmeister dritte ja und bei den männern
holte stefan baumeister den ersten
deutschen weltcup sieg in dieser saison
im olympischen parallel riesenslalom
super vorstellung von stefan baumeister
entsprechend sein jubel in italienischen
carezza zweite weltcup station der
saison führt der weltcupsieg der
karriere und ein sieg fürs
selbstvertrauen denn im finale muss er
ran gegen weltmeister logi noch links
der kurs gesteckt vom bundestrainer der
russe mit zu viel risiko verkantet
baumeister kommt sich herunter ist jetzt
weltcup gesamtführende ramona hofmeister
die erste gratulantin das deutsche team
snowboard wenige wochen vor peking schon
in olympia form
jubel also beim deutschen snowboard team
die biathletinnen dagegen enttäuschten
heute beim weltcup-rennen in logrono
beste deutsche beim sprint über 7,5
kilometer war denise herrmann die nach
zwei schießfehlern nur als vierzehnter
ins ziel kam der sieg ging an die
norwegerin marthe als reiseland
auslosung für die dritte uefa nations
league
2022/23 heute in león und da hat
deutschland eine schwere gruppe erwischt
das team von bundestrainer hansi flick
trifft auch europameister italien
england und auf ungarn die gruppenspiele
finden im juni und im september
2022 statt letzter großer test also vor
der fußball wm in katar
ja und gestern abend fußball bundesliga
ein irrer kick zwischen gladbach und
frankfurt die eintracht gewann 3 2 die
borussia nach der vierten niederlage in
folge mit ex frankfurter im freien fall
die luft wird immer dünner für adi
hütter vor der saison als großer
hoffnungsträger für 7,5 millionen euro
aus frankfurt verpflichtet jetzt mit
einer erneuten pleite gladbach taumelt
richtung abstiegszone bitteren
niederlage natürlich unglückliche
niederlage und
gratulation nochmal unterstand 14 zwar
geht die borussia mit 1 0 in führung
durch neuhaus doch anschließend zeigt
sie mal wieder große abwehrprobleme bori
trifft zum 1 1 und linth strömt zum 2 1
für frankfurt
und auch wenn gladbach durch einen
benzin elfmeter aufschließt nur 65
sekunden später erneut ein gegentor das
drei zu zwei für frankfurt kanada die
eintracht jubelt und in gladbach wird
ungemütlich
alle partien alle tore des 16 spieltag
zusammengefasst zu sehen beim zdf
heute.de und in der zdf- heute- app
dagegen arbeitet und wir bleiben
sportlich und zeigen etwas fast
unglaubliches aus der us basketball
profiliga schauen sie mal gleichstand in
der letzten spielsekunde dann dieser
wurf aus 19 metern scheinbar irgendwo
hin und drin die monty graham lässt in
new orleans pelicans jubel und das ganze
nochmal weil es so schön war höher
weiter
sieger
das wetter dagegen bleibt eher grau mit
etwas sonne und wenig regen näheres
gleich von katja hoppe war claus kleber
begrüßt sie um 21 uhr 45 im heute
journal
viele sehen
[Musik]
guten abend das ist die aktuelle
wetterlage das hoch zafira liegt über
west- und mitteleuropa hält die meiste
sonne von uns fern aber auch die große
kälte die verbirgt sie hier nördlich von
dem tief matteo in russland jetzt in der
nacht ist es meist wieder stark bewölkt
bis bedeckt es bildet sich zum teil
nebel und ab und zu kann es auch etwas
nieseln total das ist auch klar wie hier
zwischen berlin und brandenburg und der
ostseeküste die temperaturen in dieser
nacht sinken meist auf 7 bis 2 grad
kälter wird es über schnee an den alpen
oder auch im schwarzwald und auf der alb
mit 0 bis -5 grad und an den alpen über
schnee bleibt auch morgen über tag am
kühlsten mit 3 grad sonst ist es für
mitte dezember recht mild mit
höchstwerten zwischen 4 und maximal 10
grad ähnlich wie heute ist es auch
morgen eher trüb im nordosten und im
südwesten zeigt sich hin und wieder die
sonne und in den nächsten tagen wird es
von tag zu tag etwas kälter guten abend